what's up guys so being visual effects
artists we're really big into 3d
scanning we've been using it a ton in
the past for rag dolls and models and
things we need for various visual
effects shots but very recently we've
started taking this skill and instead of
applying it on screen we've been
applying it off screen by doing three
scans and 3d printing so in this video
we're going to show you guys how to make
your own action figures whether you have
3d modeling skills or not in order to
make your own action figure there's
three basic things that you need the
first is a copy of occipital schenectady
we'll get into the differences later the
second thing you need is an Xbox Kinect
make sure it is one with a normal USB
port and not a proprietary Xbox port
that's crucial for getting it to work
with your PC the third thing you'll need
is either a shapeways account or a 3d
printer of your own if you want to go on
the cheap here I'd recommend a shapeways
account as it will save you a few
thousand dollars using this process you
can make everything from full colored
miniatures you see here a little bit
more like an action figure to very small
miniatures which can be used for various
role-playing games such as Dungeons &
Dragons and we'll show you what to do
for both after you've done all your gear
together you'll want to open your
scanning application if you're a
beginner without 3d modeling skills
you're going to want to use Kinect
Kinect allows you to go from scanning to
cleaning up the model to printing the
model through Shapeways all in the same
application no other skills are required
however if you are versed in 3d modeling
I highly recommend using reconstruct me
reconstruct me gives you a little bit
more detail to work with however more
cleanup work is required before you
start scanning there's a couple
considerations you want to be aware of
the Kinect has two cameras on it one is
an infrared camera that's
is depth and 3d space the other one is a
normal camera that captures color but in
order to use these properly you need a
certain amount of space about a 10 to 15
foot radius generally around your
subject do not wear anything that's
reflective because the bouncing light
rays off this reflective material that
you might be wearing will confuse the
camera and confuse the depth and screw
up your 3d model natural sunlight has a
lot of infrared frequencies in it and
since the infrared camera unconnect uses
those to gauge depth that will also
start throwing off your scan in your
scanning program you want to make sure
that you've set your scanning area
you're scanning box to be as close in to
that person as possible to maximize the
resolution of the scan all right so I'm
turning the monitor around so I can see
it while I'm scanning I've got a USB
extension so I can walk around and have
a little more freedom to move here and
looks like our scanning area is pretty
solid here so hold perfectly still
control your breathing going in every
nook and cranny here you want to
remember to go down and look up or go up
at the top of the head tops of hands be
very carefully go behind them don't trip
over the cable our first scan of the
model is done there's still a few small
errors in it but that's okay because in
schenectady can clean that stuff up boom
I'm going to fill some holes on that
done so there's no more holes I'm also
going to colorize it in case we wanted
to print this with color and now this is
going to go back through and take all
the color data from the camera and make
that into a texture boom
it's a bowl texture here Wow look at
that how sweet is that looks pretty
sweet actually our last thing we want to
do before imprint this as you can see
there's still a lot of ground in the
shot here
we don't want to print the entire ground
plane so what you'd want to do there and
connect is you'd want to crop that out
and it's pretty easy to just quickly
orbit around select the stuff you don't
want so the last step here is if you are
using skin ech
you can simply just click on this share
feature put on the print shapeways 3d
print and log in with your shape boys
account boom and from there all you got
to do is type it in you scale it and
print it out so now that we've done our
connect person we're going to show you
the reconstruct me version this is
slightly more high detail and much
better when you're trying to make a
figurine which is super super super tiny
and so the reason Adam is standing with
his hands out like this is because later
on because we're 3d modeling experts
we're gonna be throwing a model de sword
into his hands because as you can see
when you're scanning it's hard to hold
perfectly still for 30 seconds and
having high detail objects such as a
sword or something thin there's a
natural like wobble and Shake to those
objects it's very difficult for the
scanner to catch that and also because
it yeah exactly
a sword is very reflective - bad idea
for scanners
and
that one is super solid actually and
just with the tiny bit of cleanup there
were good to go it's freaking amazing
so as you'll see on first import into
your 3d program of choice that we have
similar issues as we didn't connect I
will go in to the vertices of the piece
here and you can just quickly select
them all and delete the ground plane
it's good to select all your elements
deselect the thing that you want to keep
and hit the lead because sometimes
there's mysterious random little points
out there and I'll freak out the 3d
printer as you can see this is now Adam
on his own there is no color no texture
but we don't need that where we're going
because on the detail level that we're
going to be printing at we're going to
paint these on our own the last step you
want to do is use a modifier that will
fill the holes up you want to use a
modifier in 3ds max called cap holes if
you're not using 3ds max I'm sure there
is a equivalent one in your program the
only thing you have to do from there is
scale it to the size you want to print
it at if you're making a miniature for
Dungeons and Dragons like this about a
inch and a half high if you're making a
miniature just for yourself it can be
any size but just be aware bigger gets
the more expensive it gets
he's actually going to model a 3d cape
in and have his figure actually being
held up by the cape model it's gonna be
kind of cool
reminds me Max Payne maybe read the
first one yeah
reading constantly girls sing that was
sweet look like just a little tweaked
knee on the legs
now actually playing smaller that's
pretty solid I don't think I've learned
something from this small introduction
into the world of 3d scanning and 3d
printing if you guys want to try this
out I highly recommend trying out either
skin act or reconstruct me depending on
your skill level and I highly highly
recommend using
shapeways as a 3d printing source
because of the vast amount of materials
they have if you guys have any questions
about 3d printing or applications leave
them in the comments below or hit us up
on twitter at corridor digital thanks
for watching